ladies and gentlemen welcome to tim cast
irl i want to start this show with my
heartfelt condolences to the trump
family we got news uh not that long ago
that ivana trump had passed away cardiac
arrest and uh obviously she's the mother
of many of the trump children and it's
just it's sad to hear uh there's some
pretty brutal videos seeing that the
trump kids are very devastated by this
so uh i just want to say everyone here
uh wishes them well and we give our
condolences and uh
we might just get into the story later
on because it is it's very important but
you know sad stuff as we start the show
but we do have big news in the trump
family outside of the the saturn news
donald trump gave an interview to i
think it was new york mag where he
essentially announced he is running in
every conceivable way that he could he
said he was running without literally
saying he was running and it was it was
it was brilliant it was so trumpian he's
like i've made a decision and when i
announce people aren't going to want to
run because i'm holding better than them
he basically said it so it's like okay
we get it you're running
the thing is if he formally declares
that he's running it puts a bunch of
laws in play like also he's he's
beholden to a bunch of fec laws and
regulations so
this is why people always do these
things
so uh we'll we'll talk about that plus
you've got elon musk's statements about
ryan desantis and we love talking about
trump versus rhonda sanders so we'll get
into that and then we've got a bunch of
other news ocasio-cortez basically said
january 6 was an inside job she said the
police held the door open for that like
they did and i agree with her she said
she wants an investigation to deep dive
into these cops who seem to have been
involved and i'm like yes please
unfortunately the news about aoc is
completely being distracted from because
alex stein yelled that she had a big
booty so that's the news in the cycle
and it's it's so annoying but of course
they're gonna try and distract from
something very important aoc said i am
with aoc 100 on that investigate those
cops who held the door open get down on
the j6 committee and show the world cops
held the door open who were they why
were they doing it we also got our our
good friend malcolm nance saying that
the republican party's been radicalized
and we may have to fight our neighbors
now the rhetoric's getting really crazy
so we're getting all that before we do
head over to timcast.com
and become a member to support the work
we're doing here we have a bunch of new
shows in the works we have some comedy
specials in the works we've got a big
announcement coming very very soon
i know i keep saying that but trust me
it is coming and it's just because we
got to deal with all these technical
issues but we're doing some big
infrastructure changes which i'm really
excited for click that sign up button in
the top right become a member we're
gonna have a members only show the after
hours show at 11 pm tonight you don't
want to miss it it's uncensored and uh
we say naughty things and tell very
funny funny jokes and it's it's a good
time you'll also be supporting our
journalists so don't forget to also
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
and tonight joining us to talk about the
news is vanessa santos
hello tim thank you so much for having
me yes so uh who are you i am the ceo of
red renegade pr um i started my firm
to be an aggressive doesn't take no for
an answer pr firm that that fights
woke-ism wherever we find it
i make sure our clients have a voice and
can be heard too often over the years
i've seen so many people get censored or
canceled because they don't follow the
accepted view
and i have worked hard to fight against
that so
i put together my own team that rebels
against that and gives our clients a
voice right on you work with some pretty
cool people i hear a lot of prominent
people people we've had on the show for
instance so um behind some of the guests
we've had have been uh individuals like
yourself yes so here you are now today
on the show i'm i was telling
lydia earlier i decided after i had my
two boys since since kovitt hit that um
i i want to be a little more vocal
myself with the culture war because i'm
not sure i'm too
pleased with the direction the country
is going right on more people got to
speak up for sure thank you for having
me i'm very excited to be here glad to
see you we also have brett dasavic of
pop culture crisis how's it going uh yes
i am a pop culture crisis it would
normally be mary sitting here but she uh
she took the night often i don't know
what that's about normally uh yeah well
lately the last uh not the last couple
of days but yeah we do pop culture
crisis 3 p.m eastern standard time on
youtube.com uh and it sounds like you
were giving the trump school of
announcing earlier with your with your
comment about saying that you have a big
announcement coming see everyone's
announcing that they've got an
announcement coming right it's uh it's
very good marketing i'm not running for
president
that's not my announcement you've
announced you're not running that's
right yeah announce that you're going to
make an announcement about not running
exactly yes i also have an announcement
tonight josh19 zmapped on twitter asked
me to work graphing into the convo
tonight but josh i am announcing that i
will not be working graphene hexagonally
latticed carbon into the conversation
unfortunately
but thanks for the request
i am also here in the corner i'm very
excited to have vanessa i love the idea
of bringing people forward who do some
of the hard work behind the scenes that
never get any kind of attention very
important work to be done really like
the idea of platforming people who don't
often get a chance to speak so let's get
into it we're just getting more people
to speak up exactly santa for themselves
yes
it can be risky last night i was
thinking we talked about god last night
a lot and i was thinking like you know
i don't i can't speak for god obviously
no one has that authority really but
it feels like it doesn't want us to just
make money it's not about money it's
about communication and that's a big
part of it i think it's about making the
world better for everyone in every
possible way improving upon this
beautiful green earth uh maybe we'll
talk about that stuff let's jump into
this first story
trump says he's made up his mind about
2024 big decision is timing of
announcement i love this the hill
reports they say former president trump
said he has made it made a decision
about running for the white house
well in my own mind i've already made
that decision so nothing factors in
anymore in my own mind i've already made
that decision
do uh he added do i go before or after
that will be my big decision the
interviewer then said midterms and he
said midterms
let people know i think a lot of people
would not even run if i did that because
if you look at the polls they don't even
register most of these people he said
and i think that you would actually have
a backlash against them if they ran
people want me to run
he could not have said
in in any more clear terms he's running
short of outright saying i'm running
so trump 2024 i guess there we go and i
mean it is relatively early for a
president to make a bold statement like
this i know he didn't formally declare
but even with hillary the joke the meme
was she's running over and over again
because she really waited as long as
possible to even suggest she would run
what are the legal ramifications for
announcing for him you can't take money
from certain people or you can only take
a certain amount of money from certain
groups and people the the one oh it's
it's it's it's so um honorable the way
hillary clinton did it right oh yeah
because she made sure to get those big
fat goldman sachs paychecks before she
announced he was running
yeah we know how that works those very
expensive speaking engagements that's
right i feel like these laws really
incentivize people to kind of hedge and
hedge until like hillary clinton did she
got a bunch of money and then she
announced she was running it seems very
shady and it seems like we're making it
easier for them to do that and i don't
think we should make it easier for
politicians to be dishonest call me
crazy so i love this from cnn it sure
sounds like donald trump is running in
2024 oh come on chris soliza just say
trump is running we all know sure does
but i'll tell you what really frustrates
me about this and what i think is
actually the bigger story is donald
trump's penchant for
giving people who despise him the scoop
why
why does he keep helping these people
this was a big deal his informal
announcement that he's decided he's
going to run
and that he wants to announce soon and
people may drop out and he goes to
olivia nuzzy of
i think it's new york magazine and the
first thing they do let me see if we can
uh
we'll pull up this story the whole first
paragraph is just disparaging trump and
smearing him with every possible
negative story imaginable better than
this it's incredible he's the guy who
looked at who did you look at jim acosta
you are fake news
and then when when it comes to one of
the biggest announcements does he go to
breitbart does he go to human events
does he go to post-millennial does he go
to crowder or tim cast or any
independent outlet
he goes to the people the first thing
they do
this whole paragraph
i can try to read it fast it's very long
all right here we go
here's the first paragraph of donald
trump's interview with new york magazine
donald trump was impeached twice lost
the 2020 election by 7 million 52 770
votes is entangled in investigations by
federal prosecutors of the capital
insurrection and over miss handling of
classified witness documents and
over-elected interference in the
district of columbia attorney general
over financial fraud of the presidential
inaugural committee and the manhattan
district of attorney over financial
fraud of the trump organization and the
new york state attorney general of a
financial trump organization and the
western county district attorney over
financial fraud of the trump
organization and the fulton county
georgia district attorney over criminal
election interference in georgia and the
securities and exchange commission over
rules violation and plans take his
social media company public through a
spec and the house select committee on
january 6 who searing our runaway tv
ratings of the summer yet on monday july
11th he was in a fantastic mood
why would you give an interview to
someone who's gonna introduce you and
your ideas in that way you know i i
actually think that giving it to olivia
proves his uh priorities which which is
that you know he's he doesn't really
care to run for
america he cares to pick up where he
left off fighting with reporters and
getting attention yeah i think it's a
huge distraction
um
from what we really need from a
presidential candidate right now
it's unfortunate to see him doing this
right out the gate you know what this
says to me this says to me that donald
trump has learned nothing
he's learned nothing he always wanted
the media to be his friend he wanted
them to be on his side even as he was
calling them the fake news he would
still give all these super combative
interviews he has learned nothing i see
no way that he would fire the people who
need to be fired that's a good point
yeah i don't think he's going to make
any changes if he does run again even if
he does wait i i can't believe he went
to
new york mag for the keyless it's it's
absolutely bonkers well maybe for the
real announcement he'll he'll do it with
uh with an ally
maybe maybe is there any way to go it
doesn't have to be an ally has to be
somebody who's just going to
give you the news you know
is there any way to grab analytics on
this article that he that was written
about his
announcement that he's considering
announcing announcing for president uh
because he could have come out if he did
it on a show like this he'd have 1.6
million views overnight and it would be
his face and his voice which is what
gets you elected not text
except in biden's case apparently
yeah well he resisted going to any
alternative platforms for the longest
time until he had his own and he's very
clearly resisting yeah he went to this
lady holy crap take a look at this from
ground.news bias fact check olivia nuzzy
interacts 92 percent of the news she
interacts with interacts with is left
leaning look at that tiny little morsel
of right wing in there which is probably
like four percent or something
and donald trump decided that he's going
to go to the people who smear him who
defame him who attacked him who propped
up the lies who lied about kyle
rittenhouse who lie about just who lied
in defense of justice millet who lie
about him and then first chance they get
when he sits down with this woman is she
opens the entire paragraph smearing him
in every imaginable way because i want
to make sure this point is clear
just because
people who hate trump are trying to dig
up dirt on him opposition research or
investigate him doesn't mean trump did
something wrong
we are innocent until proven guilty in
this country and people who are trying
to smear trump we get it they're going
after him but she makes it the entire
introduction i wish that he just went to
i mean
name any any independent journalist it
doesn't have to be a conservative he
could have just made a youtube video and
set data did a video just him talking to
the camera it would have been
spectacular i was gonna ask who is if
you were to give an outlet other than
tim cast who do you think uh who would
have been a good site for him together
joe rogan yeah but joe rogan won't have
him on which i don't even know if i
believe that like i don't i'm not sure
about that either
given uh how rogan's been talking lately
i'm not sure if i believe that but
believe that he wouldn't have him on
that he uh turned him down for that
reason like it just doesn't seem like
him yeah i heard that joe
i just maybe just got fed up with that i
didn't hear that he got fed up with him
imagine maybe he did and he's just like
i'm done with that guy i don't
understand why joe would not have
interviewed trump it doesn't make sense
i think he wanted to at some point he
said he would host it
right but he said he would have a debate
between biden and trump before the 2020
election and that never never came to
fruition but i'll i'll
stress this point we made last time we
talked about this when joe rogan says i
won't have trump on because it would
help him think about what that means
joe
knows biden can't do it
and trump would be helped by it right
whether he intended to or not he was
outright saying donald trump would do
well and benefit from being on this show
joe biden wouldn't biden going on rogan
and like for two hours three hours right
three hours i don't think he could do
that
joe would cut him early he can't even be
trusted to walk around the white house
egg roll alone right yeah bite and can't
he has to have dress handling in there
you could no way you could handle rogan
we've been we've been having like this
inside joke about how people complain
about when they do rogan they have to go
to the bathroom so bad when they're done
that like rogan has like he loves it
like he loves the fact that these people
just like can't go to the bathroom and
they're when they're recording but you
but you can go to the bathroom on joe's
is but they were just picturing like him
being like oh we're not done yet we're
not done yet he's just playing like
waterfalls in the background went to the
bathroom on joe's show in his hallway i
believe oh my gosh sometimes they just
do a cut
and sometimes if they just carry on or
like joe smoking or whatever they just
carry on yeah so i mean people bounce
from this channel go to the bathroom
you've got to go to the if you got to go
to the bathroom go to the bathroom you
got to go yeah i mean we're just
chilling there are times and places when
not but on podcasts
it will add to the urgency of your
performances
anger temperatures rise
so glad to learn the bathroom policy
if joe biden was on with joe rogan
two scenarios would occur the first is
that he would probably be getting up to
go to the bathroom quite a lot the
second is that he would be the one
person who doesn't need never went to go
to the bathroom yep because he's set he
just got buried
i thought that's where you were going
but i wasn't sure i'm great so you went
could you imagine watching rogan with
biden and then it like joe says
something like but come on man like you
know joe rogan says come on you're
talking about
the the mass printing of money that's
gotta have some kind of inflationary
effect and then it cuts to joe and
jose's like
oh no no
no what am i doing here buy it
one more minute his eyes would go like
really wide for a second
i saw a video of uh of biden man he
looks he looks worse than people realize
poor guy well the israel are you talking
about him coming off the plane kind of
disorienting what am i doing here it
might have been that one it was a he
sniffs a little boy oh no no i saw that
but he's just like
it was who was it who said he looks like
the dude from hannibal oh my god oh yeah
i don't remember because that was last
night
yeah
that's amazing
dude biden does and uh
trump uh did did
this is funny we just mentioned the
other day
trump needs to announce asap
because it puts biden in the worst
possible position
if biden drops out
due to his health or whatever after
trump runs
you know our trump announces then he's
like oh joe biden ran away scared the
democrats know they're not going to win
it would look really really bad and a
big component to elections is many
people vote for whoever they think is
going to win it's a weird thing about
people in this country especially
so that's bad or what if joe bows out
due to
or the democrats pull him out like
either way if trump announces and then
biden is is out for some reason
the democrats are going to lose
significant support if they have any at
all do you think that's still an issue
here uh with this polarizer climate as
we have right now that people are still
voting for who they think is going to
win
you know maybe maybe maybe some people
i'll tell you the crazy thing there was
an article in axios talking about the
realignment about how uh the republican
party has become more uh
diverse racially diverse and more
working class and the democrats have
become whiter and wealthier that it's
for sure trump lost white white votes
that's the crazy thing
he gained votes in the black community
the latino community along the rio
grande valley and so the democrats are
becoming the elite white
they're the elite white liberals
so their concerns are not what regular
people are concerned with no i mean
just just looking at the big issues that
they're trying to talk about they're so
obsessed with abortion and
you know and and pronouns and uh and and
calling
well people the right pronoun and then
meanwhile
real americans are trying to get to work
they're trying to fill their tanks i
mean it's it's so out of touch i wanna i
wanna i wanna play this clip for all you
guys
for those big fans joe biden i got a
clip for you
steve guest says joe biden tries to
shake hands with nobody again
and he does and here's the video of joe
biden
yeah the idea was in the wrong setting
time darn it here we go here we go we
got it we got you everybody here we go
thank you president herzog and president
okay we're gonna we're gonna do a
slow-motion play-by-play
here we have president joe biden at the
podium he goes to shake the hand of this
man i don't know that guy is and he
turns to reach his hand out who's over
there and there's no one there here's
the best part wait you really got to see
this
he reaches his hand out to shake pauses
and then looks at his hand like he's
tripping look at that oh my gosh what
did you see that on he just points he's
like going this way but it's the
weirdest thing where he like he reaches
his hand out and then he just like looks
at it like
what is this thing attached to me by my
body
oh my gosh if it was hunter it'd be
because he'd been up for three days at a
time and he wasn't seeing things but
like it really does uh and speech repeat
the line it's uh it gets harder and
harder to ignore um for regular people
and i do think that the average ordinary
citizen maybe the reason trump has not
like kept his uh
going the way that things are is because
he feels like any deviation from things
will mix up the momentum of letting them
screw up what they're doing never
interrupt your enemy yeah joe biden when
he ran he didn't actually run you know
he kept calling a lid yeah and when you
watch this video he reaches his arm out
he's not pointing he's reaching his arm
out open palm and then he just looks at
his hand look at that he's like he's
like staring at his hand no one here now
here's the best part the last time this
happened
politifact said president joe biden was
confused turned around and shook hands
with thin air after a speech false
how did they square that circle they
said oh he was just gesturing to the
crowd it's like dude he did it again
this is the game they play yeah it's
like joe biden could fall down and start
screaming and they would be like he was
auditioning for a movie actually totally
normal the first time he ever said end
of quote they were like he's not reading
the prompter wrong he's it was part of
the speech
most people say end of quote when
they're ending a quote then he says it
again
repeat the line
he goes end of quote repeat the line
it's dude you read the instructions
it's luck man it's a run burgundy moment
last night i was praying for this man's
mental health just his health in general
as much as i understand that he's bad at
his job i want him to fail so let's just
harp on him until he's gone but a
sick-minded president can ruin the world
so we need yeah maybe not we need to
support him in some way acknowledging
that he doesn't shouldn't be the
president ian
a sick-minded president could ruin the
world he's doing it
he is ruining the world right now he
gave a million barrels of our strategic
oil reserves he surrendered to the
taliban yeah come on come on man he gave
our oil to china hey jaina to sign a
pack
and then the media is fact checking me
being like tim pool's opinion on that
being a bad thing is wrong
okay dude when he bit his wife's hand
during the speech too
that was funny remember when he was in
the shower yeah you know that yo you see
that picture she's like she reaches out
and then he goes like
that's right it's amazing that's what my
cat does to me that was still on the
campaign trail i remember when he mixed
up his sister and his wife that was
weird yeah that was weird yeah we should
have known oh it's no big deal he just
nibbled on his wife's finger in a
bizarre campaign
it's just a loving a loving nibble very
cute affectionately yes it's a sign that
but there's there's no trouble in
paradise the bidens are romantic and
happy yeah well to be fair you know to
say joe biden bites wife is a little bit
over the top biden bites but by him
bites wife but i think what you see with
a story like this is that he's just not
cognizant of his surroundings
like he's lost his filter yeah you you
don't you don't do this
and then everyone was like oh it was
funny it was you know his wife and he's
not funny yeah it's not funny it's
terrifying it's not weird it's so weird
look at this
what is this
what is this image somebody sent me that
picture today and they're like why does
this picture exist and i was like that
really happened her hand is cold
i was hungry come on man
i thought it was a snack
i don't know dude
you know butterfingers yeah
well so look trump trump informally
announces he's running but this poll
comes out the new york times uh time
center poll saying that 44 to 41 biden
wins
there's obviously other polls saying
that's complete bunk there's another
poll i was reading today that said trump
wins 43 to 41. it's gonna be too close i
just can't imagine
and this could be hubris
that joe biden could beat trump in a
rematch
it's like it's one thing when when biden
shows up says i'm gonna run against
trump
and then
all the media does is say that covet is
trump's fault yeah and then says nothing
about joe biden jobiden hides yeah so
the only news story it was crazy because
we mentioned this back during the
campaign i was like if the media only
focuses on trump then there's going to
be nothing about biden so people will be
voting against trump and that's that's
what happened
yeah so now joe biden is known to people
and they're not happy with it joe
biden's approval rating in aggregate is
lower today than where trump's was at
the same time as presidency and here's
the best part his approval rating is
lower today than where trump's was after
january 6.
wow yeah does he lose just on the
economy
biden yeah why what do you mean like is
uh is that enough alone beyond the
bizarre behavior
you know i'd say yes normally but
democrats are
the party of the wealthy elites and
they're cultists they believe insane
things they're in a bubble they don't
know what's going on in the real world
they believe the cal written house lies
the covenant catholic lies they believed
jesse smallette right i don't look
imagine you're on a a sinking ship
and there's like a someone comes and
says i have a set of instructions to to
save the boat from sync and you're like
okay and the other guy walks up to you
and goes i think justice was telling the
truth and i'm the one who's in charge
you're gonna be like okay we're doomed
right
like how are we how are we going to
effectively fix this thing if that guy
is the one who's supposed to be like we
have to argue with each other over how
to save this ship
yeah so on the question of the economy i
actually saw and this was very
unsettling to me because i've been
harping about these shootings that have
been happening in red states and then in
blue states with and without gun control
and i said i think that this is going to
mean the democrats pull alongside the
republicans over the economy i think
guns are going to become more important
the economy and sure enough it's showing
that this is bringing them up alongside
the republicans as november is coming up
just like i thought it would happen so i
don't know what's going to happen
obviously but the fact that they have so
well publicized these two different
attacks whether you have gun control or
not whether you have the armed good guy
or not whether you have red flag red
flag laws or not you still have the same
effect i think that this has been
incredibly effective
strategy for them to push the concept of
guns to the forefront of the american
public's mind let me let me pull up this
real quick just to drive it home
president trump job approval from real
clear politics this is the aggregate of
all polling yeah i think they go back
what is it like 10 polls or something uh
check this out
after january 6 donald trump's approval
rating was 39.3
it tanked
joe biden today is
38.6
oh my gosh wow that's remarkable it
wasn't an event that caused it either
it's just like it's just like slowed
down
yeah it wasn't like a sharp dip like it
was with trump yeah yeah with trump like
all of a sudden everybody heard this
thing and they were like dude yeah if a
war gets started it spikes up if if some
dumb crap happens it spikes down but
this is just an example of a president
that's presiding over a sinking ship
like that and ian he's thinking do you
know
why
joe biden's approval dipped and his
disapproval spiked above his approval
rating
do you know what was the catalyst for it
i bet i know uh
i
wait which point oh right there tell me
is that understand mm-hmm
that's right
that's a big dip too after uh joe biden
surrendered
failed and i mean
this is this is one of the reasons i
believe that joe biden is not the puppet
people think he is he's more like i'm
not saying he's in charge i'm saying he
sort of is and everyone's kind of
confused but he's still being given
instruction by his aides we're trying to
help him right like you can have
you can hire someone to help you who
tells you what to do but you're still in
charge right afghanistan
was such a complete and total failure
that made no sense
made absolutely zero sense
joe biden was was
in the situation room probably going uh
a good airport then they like evacuate
bagram
the american people saw that and after
the abandoning of our troops the the was
it 13
brave men and women who were killed
outside the airport joe biden's approval
rating has never come back
that's it that's a good point that was
it that was it for me i mean the images
of the plane of the
yeah that's the tv
you got to talk to tim kennedy about
what he saw but but people just need to
realize this when ian
who has never been like a big trump guy
is like joe biden surrendered
afghanistan like is that animated about
it
i think that's a good barometer for a
lot of people who aren't particularly
active in politics i believe we should
focus on this this job of the president
as the commander of the military that is
their number one job is the
commander-in-chief of the military and
if they don't have a military mind like
donald trump whatever he didn't know
that they were playing shell games on
him and lying to him about troop
movement i he
you know hindsight's always 20 20. i
don't know what if he could have done it
better probably could have done it
better listening to kurt schlichter last
night explain like what a president
could do to take control of his military
command it sounds not that complicated
if you know what to do but these guys
didn't know what to do trump didn't know
what to do biden didn't know what to do
but will trump really do it you know
like we mentioned just a moment ago
he comes to these far left extremist
journalists and he gives them the
interview not only are their outlets
dying and they don't get the traffic
they despise the man and will lie about
him and smear him and so that's why i'm
saying you don't even have to go to a
sympathetic reporter you just go to
independent media and then force the
establishment to cover what you the
scoop you gave to somebody else or like
you mentioned do a youtube video yes of
course off the record like off the
script just talk if you don't if you
watch it back and you don't like it make
a difference make a new video but then
upload like a candid normal video being
like hey guys i've been thinking about
it it's on the horizon get ready it
would be people would be lit it would be
so exciting for people to see that and
to see him talking straight does he have
his own youtube channel
i don't know that would be the greatest
thing ever yeah if he just became a
youtuber if trump yeah
i i okay you
if like i don't i don't watch a lot of
youtube at all
i would i would legit be watching the
trump channel every day
26 million views overnight you'd be like
could you so you saw that post where he
roasted elon and he's like electric cars
that don't go from far enough
driverless cars that crash rockets
imagine him actually saying it to the
camera it would just be the best then
elon makes a video watch the apprentice
yes well okay so it's funny you brought
up the apprentice i was when i got
pregnant i got super obsessed with the
housewives and all the housewives
have appeared on the princess and on the
apprentice and a ton of them have and i
wanted to go back and watch these
apprentices i cannot find them anywhere
i think that whichever i think it might
have been nbc i don't know that could be
wrong but i think they took everything
off air it's crazy anyways
he was hysterical yeah he was like a
comedian like thinking back to some of
the stuff that he said yes i don't agree
with you know some of the the way he
phrased things and how insulting he was
no it was not presidential but man he
could make me
ask do you remember when trump blamed
the lights for making him orange yeah
he's self-aware and he's funny i have
been to so many trump rallies they are
stand-up comedy routines truly it was
like george carlin in a sense where he's
talking about mainstream political news
and issues and he was just joking about
everything and people are laughing and
clapping and i'm like this man knows how
to entertain and that's powerful that's
charisma i mean he's funnier than
comedians because comedians are trying
so hard to be these culture champions
and everything now like watching trump
just do it it's so funny only rosie
o'donnell
it was just so good it was just perfect
timing he had an answer right at the
gate everyone bursting laughing and
uproarious uproarious laughter so funny
he was a timing genius yes somebody said
that what he should have done is built
his own like oval office white house set
and then like had a youtube channel
after he after he lost the election
where he just second guesses and
pretends and does all the stuff that
they should do instead and just uh and
do that on youtube he's making a
parallel presidency he's funny and he's
self-aware but he's not quite humble
enough to make fun of himself he won't
really do it enough i think if he really
made fun of himself then he'd get a lot
more people on his side i think you're
right like i think that like on one hand
it's the the lack of humility is what
makes him a capable not capable leader
but like you have to be strong to lead
in that sense but a lot of people don't
like the fact that you're very uh that
you don't have the ability to laugh at
yourself or you don't have the ability
to take a joke at your own expense but
trump does
it doesn't matter if people are in a
cult they're in a cult you know it's
like brandon strzok his story is really
really powerful
how he thought trump was all of these
things and then he watched a video that
proved everything he thought wrong and
it was physically painful for him but he
was able to break out of it right and
and now he's like one of the biggest
trump supporters i don't know as of
right now but he became one of them but
but uh we were talking about january 6 i
want to jump to this story and i want to
give a shout out right away to uh tim
cast good friend alexandria
ocasio-cortez
uh we have this tweet here
she said remember how they were taught
there was tons of footage and evidence
of officers and others inside on january
6 supporting insurrectionists but then
everyone decided it was too politically
risky to investigate thoroughly so they
brushed under the rug and now we still
have no idea who or what is safe
i agree with aoc on this i want to play
you this video that there were actual
officers working with this and we never
got to the bottom of that and we never
got any answers about that and then to
this day we're just supposed to pretend
that that never happened
i have no idea what happened to the
people on the inside who were very
clearly sympathetic with what was going
on and opening the doors wide open for
that and we're i'm supposed to sit here
and protect
just right there yep opening the doors
pretend like none of that ever happened
and then right afterwards you have a
massive you know you just have this idea
that throwing money at that problem is
going to make it go away we could burn
somebody accountability and so this is
this is where these things are breaking
down we're not safe and it's not just
about members of congress not being safe
the staff workers are insane the
janitors aren't safe like we need to get
to the bottom of this so that's all i
gotta say what about it thank you
congresswoman i am i i am uh thoroughly
annoyed by the guy who just keeps
yelling antifa over and over again as
someone who's like been more critical of
antifa than many people who've spoken
out and criticized them from the get-go
starting with occupy wall street when we
were on the ground me and my friends and
the black black extremists were
attacking us and then eventually they
adopted the name antifa they were just
the black black extremists the same
people that we know their names many of
them and uh aoc
is
enthusiastically saying there were cops
who opened the doors
from the inside she never says the cops
opened the door says there were cops
inside people on the inside opened the
doors she doesn't make the direct
statement she's short opening the
insinuation is that there were there was
law enforcement inside she's saying she
doesn't feel safe because she doesn't
know what happened to those people who
were inside
whoever they were she's right
the american people need to know there
were people inside who opened the doors
can can we can we blast that message out
there can we stop for one second and say
look i get aoc doesn't care about antifa
riots or anything like that fine but the
one thing we do agree on we want an
investigation into the people who opened
the doors from the inside who are they
why and what does that mean for those
being criminally charged aoc is on board
why are people screaming at her yeah
their one guy got let out of solitary i
don't know if he was in solitary led out
of jail because the judge said well a
police officer waved you in you're not
liable for trespassing or whatever they
let them go and she was talking about
the safety of congress of those in
congress right what did she have to say
about um supreme court's the supreme
court justices and expanded security she
said
poor him or something like that poor guy
yeah yeah she's a hypocrite yeah but you
know what
this is the thing there are people in a
cult a cult leader just came out and
said we have this problem and i'm like
we got an invoice
now we can go to each and every one now
i can go to every one of these club
members and be like well look i agree
with aoc you know aoc wants an
investigation into these cops and the
people who open the doors from the
inside she is right about that there she
is hands down she's not wrong either
that they're not safe it's not a safe
environment to centralize your
government anymore you don't need to
have everybody sitting inside of one
building that can be surrounded like
it's just too not today it doesn't make
i don't know i'm with her man i want to
i think i don't think it's as big a deal
as you think so you think it is i you
know one of the things we said back on
january 6 was we mocked the people who
tried breaking their way in saying
why do you do you think that standing in
a building grants you political power
it's not the 1600s
so
even if they're in one building like
it's not going to disrupt
to a great degree at least the uh the us
government
i'm more intrigued by the fact that she
was like what are we just gonna throw
more money at this problem and hope that
solves it like you vote for big spending
all the time what are you talking about
you think this works for everything else
but not this i i'm looking at a
priorities list right you got aoc has
been hypocritical in terms of what
happened with the violent riots there
what happened with the riots the rest of
the country she supported people being
harassed so she gets uh alex stein yells
at her big booty latina
and for the most part i think it's a
non-story and it's it's it's stupid
anyway distraction you know so but i'm
i'm more upset that the media is using
it to distract so it is kind of dumb
but
she gets harassed and then she's like i
was i was gonna deck him oh i can't
believe he would say that to me but then
brett kavanaugh gets harassed and she
doesn't she doesn't care one bit but i i
look at that and i'm like okay there's
priorities i will criticize her for that
but then she comes out and she hits a 10
out of 10 grand slam out of the park
people open the door from the inside i
want an investigation i'm like bingo
there it is that's what we want to hear
right steve bannon said something
similar this is uh months and months ago
maybe even a year ago or whatever he was
like i want an investigation he's like i
i want a hearing let's get an
investigation to exactly what happened
on january 6 and i'm like
oh well all right okay because the idea
is a legitimate investigation why were
there cops standing around as people
pleaded for them to intervene you see
the video the guy goes to the cops what
are you doing please stop this the cops
just do don't move why weren't there
enough cops there where was the national
guard
why were people opening the door from
the inside
those questions need to be answered
one guy got acquitted of all charges
because the judge saw a video of cops
waving them in
that legit waving them in
we need answers i i play a lot of video
games crusader kings if you can get your
enemy committing a petty crime you can
throw him in prison and strip him of all
his all his land and all his titles and
erase him from well it's like a petty
crime in grand theft auto you guys ever
played gta mm-hmm you play you have
played it yeah uh ian
you still love it what you do is
you
in the video game if you go up to a
random person and attack them
and then they fight back and you run to
a police car the police will start
brutally beating the person who is
attacking you so and i'm talking about
trick him i'm talking about political
like like your own subordinates like if
you're a king and it's your duke and you
don't like him and you catch him doing
some slander or something you can throw
him a person yeah if someone if someone
lets him in if you open the door so that
he can commit a crime you can throw that
guy in prison like
there's a reason to let people commit
crimes for authorities sometimes because
then you got them and i want to know if
that's what they did take a look
oh sorry no i was just i think it might
have been you guys last night on
on the show uh with libby and kurt but
some somebody raised the question you
know why is there only
select footage being released like
release everything like let's just
make it all public take a look at this
story from the daily mail
secret service deleted texts from
january 5th and 6th homeland security's
inspector general reveals amid its
internal probe
why yeah they say many texts between the
u.s secret service were deleted after
the watchdog made a request for
electronic communications the letter
states
yo
the right seems to think that if we get
a real investigation it'll prove that
feds were involved
the left seems to think it'll prove that
trump orchestrated the whole but i think
i don't care one way or the other alex
is insulin i think she's the kind of
mind that's like if we get evidence that
the cops let people in and and incited
this then we've got innocent people in
prison and this is
beyond effed and and
a lot of people in the establishment of
that were the case wouldn't want her to
turn like that they want those people
insulated thinking that they were just
attacked by a mob right because it's
convenient i think regardless of what
the the end result is
if police opened the doors and that and
as a fact they did there are cops who
opened the door and said i don't agree
with it but i respect it they said that
to those to people there's video cop
waving at people waving them to come in
they've argued oh no the cop was waving
at um uh other cops
it's like i i don't know work here
there's a video of them fanning at the
trump supporters who then started
walking in there are people movies
pictures of yes yeah they're taking
selfies yeah if that was part of the
january 6th hearings which is not
the american people would be here would
be would be feeling some they'd be
feeling very different about what
happened instead i'm hearing about how
people saw my clip posted by jamie
raskin out of context and they don't
know or care what i actually said the
smear is intentional what they're doing
is intentional they're lying and
manipulating now
the good news for us is that we're part
of a new sect of media where we have
massive key demo viewership most people
who watch this are like 30 we get 18 to
54 we get it very very well but you have
millions who are watching cnn msnbc and
fox news
and fox news not the worst not all that
great
that's where the old people are and so
they believe all the nonsense now the
funny thing is whenever the january
january 6 hearings are on fox news his
ratings tank so they just like try not
to do it
because nobody wants to watch that stuff
manipulation and lies does do we know
what the actual ratings have been for
the january 6 hearings because i see a
lot of like like whenever i'm doing
research for what we're covering you
still get a lot of like that stuff like
deadline uh hollywood reporter they're
covering it because it's technically
part of the the
media stream right they're high but low
okay like they they got like tens of
millions of viewers across the board but
it's relatively low compared to every
other hearing people really are tuning
out from this stuff why
the average person does not like joe
biden this is the funny thing with joe
biden at a hitting record low approval
ratings down to like 37.7
and i've said it before the opportunity
there two-thirds of this country doesn't
like the guy okay make fun of him it's a
big market share
but they don't
you'd think every single person would be
like look if i want votes
bet against biden everybody hates him
instead they're not doing it they're
passively in behind the scenes being
like we need to get somebody else
but where are the late night hosts to be
like ladies and gentlemen who watch this
show i know you all hate joe biden
because even democrats don't want him to
run but for some reason they just keep
propping him up i thought watching
colbert really go at kamala harris on
that interview it was like a year ago or
something he's like when you were
running against joe biden you said
horrible stuff like it was a debate
and he's like so what it's okay to lie
if it's a debate but steve he hasn't
like come out and be like i cannot stand
that woman she lied yeah she
put
like i want to see him honest about his
feelings for kamala harris well i want
to know what happened to kamala because
it seems like when she was running
against him she was in a chad felix
screen i follow him on twitter i love
his tweets he's very smart um but he he
tweeted the other day this this point
basically which was you know we we saw a
woman who was so well spoken she was uh
you know she would cut your throat you
know and she and and now her sentences
don't even make sense it's just strange
she seems so targeted and so fearless
and and it's just strange to see what's
happened to her like it's like every
step she's about to fall it feels like
she's about to fall into lava is what it
looks like she's so nervous to say the
wrong thing that she just says he's
ridiculous circular circular yeah yeah
that's right that is interesting i
hadn't thought about that but you're
right yeah she was a prosecutor she was
an ambitious woman i don't have a high
opinion of ambitious women but they get
stuff done you know i always thought of
her as like somebody who really speaks a
lot in like declarative sentences right
right it's like i'm going to cut to the
chase this is the point
and now it's
skirt around in circles and say nothing
and it's very weird to see it she's
expected to live a lie now because she
really didn't like joe biden and was
very overt about that during the debates
and now she's got to pretend like it so
it's make when you live a lie people
become crazy nervous wrecks i mean
that's that's to me it seems like it's
the only explanation i mean but you know
if if if they don't run biden
i mean what is she doing for her
political future at this point if she
can't even
make a sentence
i don't i don't get it yeah there's no
way she got to where she is today by
using those weird auto-correct
predictive text sentence style of
speaking she used to be very like i feel
like she was evil in the way she worked
but she worked she worked she got stuff
done she made people you know work for
free she enslaved people that's right
but she did all of these things
competently whatever you thought of what
she did and now she's like i think
you're right i think she's terrified and
you're right she's not doing anything
for her political future all she's doing
is picking fights with people in the
white house like people it's an
incredibly toxic workplace like working
with an ambitious lady like that is very
toxic there it becomes a very
um it becomes an entangling battle of
wills where they feel like they're being
slighted over every little thing and
it's like how are you supposed to make
progress with that and there's no way
for a lady like that to do to for
example get into office nobody wants her
for president she i believe she's far
less like uh she's far less liked even
even joe biden and that's way less like
than donald trump was at this point yeah
she does give off like incredibly
nervous energy yeah like somebody who
starts talking but forgets what they're
about to say and has to kind of make it
up as they go yeah but you know what i
mean yeah i know and yeah it's well it's
like that michael scott quote sometimes
i start a sentence yeah i forget where
i'm going
keep making it exactly all of that
sounds like that when she's talking like
when she does the circular logic that's
what it sounds like yeah no i i
completely agree it's gotta be like
psychologically debasing to know that
you were selected for your
office because of the color of your skin
right like if they're like we need a guy
with long hair
ian you can do it like i'd be like well
i guess that blows
i do meet the requirements yes thanks
yeah well that's kind of how i feel
about their press secretary she was
literally chosen because of her skin
color and her sexual orientation
grading can i read some inspirational
quotes for you guys behind it yes oh
from amelia harris yes let's do it
my favorite we must together work
together to see where we are where we
are headed where we are going and our
vision for where we should be but also
see it as a moment to yes
together address the challenges and to
work on the opportunities that are
presented by this moment
here's another one what else do we know
about this population 18-24 they are
stupid i remember that
inspiring
ukraine is a country in europe it exists
exists next to another country called
russia
russia is a bigger country russia is a
powerful country russia decided to
invade a smaller country called ukraine
so basically that's wrong she's reading
children's books
she's an auto text robot
it's like chat bots are more more
inspiring this is my favorite quote from
her it is time for us to do what we have
been doing and that time is every day
i mean it could be worse she didn't say
end quote repeat the line that's true
that's a good point
what
is yeah
it's pretty bad yeah
we all watched the television coverage
just yesterday that's on top of
everything else that we know and don't
know yet based on what we've just been
able to see and because we've seen it or
not doesn't mean it hasn't happened oh
what
what
predictive text generator
oh my gosh it's time for us to do what
we've been doing and that time is every
day i'm so inspired oh man that's
amazing deep thoughts
is there just something going around
this white house that makes people lose
their ability to communicate is that
just the leftism is it just nervous
energy i i actually like
like she even had her posture even seems
like her shoulders are super tense yeah
i mean like she doesn't seem like she's
actually ready for any of her public
interactions what we must do she's kind
of looking down a lot too
what we must do yes today
with these times is do what we've done
when we really had me for a second
in times like now yes
i am inspired those are fun to say
tim well it's fun because everyone's
listening to you and they're looking at
you and you know you're not saying
anything
and so it's just like keep looking
i've got you all man
all right all right all right take a
look at this story from breitbart this
is great tim cast's good friend malcolm
nance says gop becoming an insurgency we
may have to fight our neighbors okay
whoa well guys i'm worried because
malcolm nance he's he's got a gun and i
saw that picture of him in military gear
when he went to ukraine and you know
terrifying he knows what he's doing this
is interesting are we gonna listen to
this malcolm dan center speaking at all
well it's five minutes of him just like
diarrheaing from his mouth essentially
he's talking about the united states
diarrhea-ing a word
but it should be it's a good verb it uh
he's not wrong that we are facing some
sort of insurgency but i believe it's a
federal reserve it's a fascist
attempt at a coup basically since 1913
you know rockefeller jp morgan they
wanted control of the country so they
created this this private bank to run
our our finances and we have yet to
break free so in that he's right we are
in trouble and we have been co-opted but
he points the finger at donald trump
which is very annoying because i feel
like it's the bank the banking industry
he thinks it's people at parent-teacher
conferences right yeah he thinks it's
his neighbors that's terrifying i think
ian's thinking correctly when he says
it's someone above us who's trying to
pit us against each other
that's correct i'm just imagining like
malcolm nance like walks out of his
house and there's like a guy in like
cargo khaki cargo shorts with like a
tucked in polo shirt and he goes how do
you neighbor and nancy goes
brutally attacking him that's fake gun
you're far right so let me let me i want
to read this quote but i really don't
want to
he said you can call what is happening
in insurgency we have heard that term in
foreign wars recently in iraq today we
uh uh he says to talk about why you
apply the term insurgency to what you
see here as a person's an ongoing threat
of domestic extremism so that was that
was a zerlina asking him
he said i was reading their forms i was
reading their own intelligence about
what they intended to do it was pretty
clear at that point that they were going
to try to either overthrow the
government or they were going to settle
in for a long-term series of
destabilizing actions using a political
party the republican party as their
political base and then using violence
threat of violent extremism as a way to
manifest change in the street i just
want to say it
the gen the goal of january 6 we thought
was to was to stop trump from running it
really does feel in my opinion the goal
is to start a civil war that's what it
sounds like yeah the the end result of a
non-adversarial
just smear campaign
show trial
it is similar to the things we've seen
in other countries when people are
trying to destabilize and destroy a
government it makes me think of the
burning of the reichstag and hit what
hitler did well we don't know that
hitler this is different he said the
communists did no no this is more like
the french revolution or so
it's a show trial it's bringing people
up then that no one defends any of the
individuals no one can no one's given a
chance to nobody want most people don't
want to and then they they lie cheat and
steal to present their case to try and
seize power yeah i don't think like with
the reichstag i think hitler did it he
just chose he's like i'm gonna do it and
i'm gonna lie and then i'm gonna strip
them of their rights and in this case no
one like did it it just happened but
they're using the experience as an
opportunity to seize to their people in
jail without a trial to enhance security
i don't think that's the goal of january
6. they already threw people in jail
without a trial put them in solitary
january 6 is is fomenting
discord in this country it is convincing
people of nonsense psychotic bs like
this malcolm nance is radicalized he is
as radicalized as you can be he's saying
he needs to fight his neighbors
if i were to have told you six years ago
that msnbc
personality would go on tv and say we
may have to fight our neighbors
would you have believed me you'd be like
oh come on
then if i said
it's the year is 20 2015. let's go seven
years you know nobody believes trump's
gonna win and you go back in time and
you go to any random person and say
seven years from now
several uh presidential administration
officials former officials will have
been arrested by the incoming
administration
prominent msnbc personalities we'll be
talking about civil war and one of them
will say we may have to be fighting our
neighbors
a man walking down the street in
portland will be shot twice in the chest
by a man with a communist tattoo on his
neck the red salute nobody would have
believed you
and today people are acting like nothing
crazy is happening it's like stop being
the frog in the boiling pot the average
person
doesn't know about the the guy getting
shot with the yeah that's like that's my
biggest problem is like most of my
friends if they're not politically
partisan the ones that i don't agree
with but we can at least agree to
disagree the average person just doesn't
know that stuff is going on there they
if it's not being you talked about
donald trump report you know going to
these sites that hate him to get his
message out there that's part of the
problem that's but these other sites
they're not talking about this that you
know when that happened i still remember
that nobody heard about that in the
regular news nobody around me i think i
think that's the problem too you know
these these people don't want to be
political you know it's doomsday news
all the time all the time they think
they're leading this happy life but
you know
ultimately they're not voting they're
not doing anything and the next thing
you know
like their kids are coming home with
these crazy messages and
they're
i mean i i i don't know i wish i wish i
felt like i could
be non-political but i i care too much
and i think
i think you know you guys obviously do
that's why we're here yeah we had this
uh tim tweeted this plato quote about uh
if you don't get him involved in
politics the politics will get involved
with you well he says that penalty for
not being involved is to be ruled by
evil and then you juxtapose that with
dantone uh who said i'd rather have been
a poor fisherman than to have meddled in
the politics of man what i started
thinking is dantone was cynical he was
angry and violent the entire time and he
was just lashing out of course you're
supposed to be involved with politics
here let me let me read these quotes
plato said the price good men pay for
indifference to public affairs is to be
ruled by evil man correct and dantone
said oh it were better to be a poor
fisherman than to meddle with the
government of memphis that is not true
that is an fu to people because he was
angry that they were about to execute
him that's right he knows you have to be
involved in the political process you
don't have to be partisan but you need
to be involved in what's going on you
need to know what's going on and be
willing to communicate and be willing to
listen
it is the basis of our government is
that we the people created this thing
together and we're running this thing
yeah i think that's a personal
reflection on the part of dan tone i
think it was very a sense of deep regret
and frustration that he did what he did
i don't know if he ever realized or said
that it was something that needed to be
done but at the end of the day it even
if you regret doing something sometime
it's sometimes it is far better to have
done that thing than to have not done it
and no better example
of uh living by the sword and dying by
the sword or diamond sword then uh
robespierre
and danton yeah i was thinking last
night the u.s revolution the french
revolution and the french man they had
it tough because the king was there with
them on their soil like we were far away
and they had
they ended up cutting all these people's
heads off with the guillotine like could
they have won that revolution if they
hadn't done that
well that's the danger of monarchy it
makes people crazy and desperate think
about the the russian revolution
when or not russian but soviets or ever
you call it when they when they brought
the royal family and we're like yeah
just wait here and then later came back
and just killed them all yeah they were
like the problem is if you're around
you'll have influence so you're dead
these people are dangerous crazy people
the french revolution is
man people you got to read about that
i've only read a little bit but i'm
reading more and y'all should read about
it because it was a group of people
there was anger in the streets they were
starving so they have a revolution it
happens then a bunch of different
factions are all in a mexican standoff
over who's going to get who's going to
chop off whose head and they all start
executing each other and everyone and
then finally robespierre gets it and
they're like yay like we finally killed
the last person who was trying to get
power
creepy and then napoleon seized command
and became an emperor that's what
happened to that nonsense that's great
and then you get the napoleonic wars
we do not want to fight our neighbors to
be clear the the nazis separated people
from their neighbors the communists in
russia separated people from their
neighbors they had their neighbors
spying turning in their neighbors their
kids turning in their parents
so i understand nancy's frustration and
it's and fear i get that he is afraid
but right now you need to be
communicating with your neighbors and
creating community with your neighbors
if you run out of food you need to make
sure that your neighborhood is secure
together and that you all have enough
food to eat you need to import the food
make sure the roads are clear
have community watch
i think malcolm nance saying this is a
sure sign that he hasn't talked to
another actual person outside his bubble
in a very long time there are a lot of
normal people
who just want to take their kids to
school without masks you know argue
about that with other people they're not
terrorists they're working they're
trying to provide their family with them
they don't have time to engage with this
local school board who has time right
let me read what he said
he said a year and a half ago when i was
calling as an insurgency people were
saying it's crazy this isn't an
insurgency this isn't like iraq it's not
like libya it's not like syria well it
is it's well in its way it's closer to
the beginnings of the irish republican
army you know irish republicanism where
now the republican party is sin fine is
it how you pronounce it yes
uh and it's just a matter of seeing who
comes up as the original irish
republicans in this story and starts
carrying out acts of violence to affect
change
that's already happening with anti-funds
been happening so we are well on our way
to a multi-year campaign that we are
already two years into into this
campaign where we may have to fight them
the they in my title and the they in my
title is those who want to kill
americans are your neighbors
that's so horrible
if we don't have a king man we don't
have a a monarch
oh i think this is a typo from breitbart
maybe the they in my title
and those who want to kill americans are
your neighbors or i don't know okay he
might have referred to they in the title
of his article but yeah to me it just
sounds like he's calling you to go out
in the streets and uh get into it with
your own neighbors
the irish republicans wanted out of the
british empire they were stuck under
imperial rule they didn't like it that's
not what we're going through right now
we're suffering a bank default basically
the people on the left think that it's a
white supremacist 1619 government and
they look
hugh controls the past controls the
future is that the saying yeah you
control or no that's not what it is is
it let me look it up not sure i thought
that sounded right to me yeah yeah
because like there's like a full quote
it's like who controls the future
controls the present or something or
controls the president
present will be controlled by those who
in the past
lived in the few i'm sorry
now yes
vice president
all right thank you you have the quote
no i'm pulling it up sorry my phone's
really slow i had to update it you're
saying who writes the history books is
sort of predominating the future you go
to people and say
hey did you know that guy
stole from you and you go he did yeah he
stole from you why did he steal from me
because of your race like but i can't do
anything about that um you should beat
them up and that's what you end up
getting you get these extremists who are
advocating for this crazy stuff okay
here's the quote who controls the past
controls the future who controls the
present controls the past yeah there you
go yeah works out
powerful and that's what we're seeing
with people like malcolm nance yeah um
the idea
it's possible he's just so dumb
that he doesn't know how to read or he
doesn't want to read i don't buy that
anymore yeah i used to be one of the
people that gave people the benefit of
the doubt and thought you know maybe
they just don't know what they're doing
zombies i i don't i don't buy that
anymore i don't think so yeah so
if that's the case then it's intentional
he's intentionally trying to manipulate
the facts the data history to cause
people to be violent this is the point i
was making with my op-ed in newsweek
jamie raskin who represents a district
like two miles away from us
who represent some of the employees here
at tim cast
was was spreading disinformation to
radicalize people yep because they want
violence yeah so his article reads more
like a wish than a warning it sounds
like this is exactly what he wants it's
what he's been gunning for he's been
sounds like calling for it for a long
time the idea that he said that
incredible that we that
we what he says that uh where we may
have to fight them
that's outright psychotic like i get it
you do want to prepare for the worst you
want to be that's why people arm
themselves in the u.s so we have the
second amendment a big part of is
because if if you get a totalitarian
government could be your neighbors or
whatever you need to be able to defend
yourself i understand the sentiment but
there's a there's a there's like a
a point where
preparing and living in fear no longer
is defensive but becomes offensive
and we got to make sure that people
that spew rhetoric like this do not
incite people to attack their neighbors
preemptively
so vanessa i'm really curious what your
thoughts on this are as a suburban
mother of young children what do you
think of this idea that someone's
actively trying to sew discord between
you and the people who literally live
next door to you yeah i mean
i already feel outnumbered by my
community because i'm i lean
conservative obviously and um you know
i'm smack in the middle of
dc a suburb in dc and um
you know
it's funny
somebody made a comment about how you
can tell who the conservatives are
because they're the ones who are flying
the american flags
and um
you know
somebody asked me when i was when i was
gonna vote uh you know would you put the
person's name up in your yard and the
answer was no i i don't i really don't
want my neighbors to know my politics i
i don't i don't want to have the
conversation i've got a nice
big jeep that i don't want messed with i
um this is why
the cult forms because these people
they i think
it makes me not want to engage and
that's what's scary what i'm saying is
if they don't ever see it they assume
it's fringe or doesn't exist yeah and
there's probably a bunch of people in
your neighborhood who do agree with you
but the people who are in the cult
think everyone thinks the same way they
do because you don't want to put signs
up in your yard if i did not have two
very small children
i would be a little more fearless about
it but i don't i mean
i i don't wan i don't want my stuff
smashed because somebody sees you know
maybe if i was supporting trump i don't
want them seeing a trump sticker you
know whoever runs i i suppose the the
issue then is if you think you can keep
your head down and they won't come and
smash your stuff you're wrong and by
your your unwillingness to actually
stand up for yourself is only making the
problem worse no i mean that's that's a
i mean you know and i work with um
i work with some different groups who
are recruiting
parents to run for a school board and
that's you know this is the big
conversation that they're having too
which is you know how how like are you
going to be
too scared to get up in your community
to really
like help kind of con take back the
education system
it's it's it's this is what i'm saying
though suburban mom it is scary because
you
you have to worry about
about your kids and how your kids are
going to fit in and how people are going
to treat your children and that's why um
well i also think that my demographic is
the hardest to figure out where we're at
politically because
most women i think feel my way it's like
we're going to vote how we vote but
we don't want to talk about it why would
you want your kids hanging out with
their kids no you're right they're going
to be grooming your kids this is a
conversation that i've had with my
husband too about leaving the area um
and going to a red state even even even
uh
eastern west virginia and it's funny to
say eastern
uh the schools have been infiltrated by
by the world because when they when they
run for school board they don't put any
affiliation and they don't they
they know they have to lie when the when
the republicans were questioning those
witnesses the other day and they refused
to condemn infanticide it's because they
know if they admitted their position
people would recoil in horror so they
know they have to lie so what happens is
in these west virginian schools
you have wokeness critical race theory
and gender ideology and they tell the
kids hide it from your parents it's even
in west virginia you got to go deeper
into western you get away from it and
there's been a big backlash where locals
finally started figuring out what's
going on with their kids and now people
are pulling their kids out that's that's
a big that's happening
so i come from a single mom home
and
you know
we used to kind of joke i mean she she
was able to make it to all my soccer
games she made it all my sporting events
but she worked her butt off all the time
to make sure that my sister and i were
were supported and you know there was
one time i was busting her balls and
it's probably not even fair for me to
have done this looking back now but you
know she couldn't name my math teacher
one year
and how many
i mean
note these parents who work these
parents who don't have the capacity to
engage with school boards all this stuff
i mean this you know critical race
theory and the gender ideology teachings
it's it's happening and parents have no
idea and i actually think it's worse
with
these more rural schools without so many
eyes on them because
they they have staff that aren't really
being checked
like you know a a teacher can probably
get away with more because
you know the the parents aren't as tuned
in the school board's not as tuned in
they can kind of i don't know i i know
that there was some teachers kind of in
rural wisconsin who were getting in
trouble for this and
um
anyway to your point though my husband
and i have talked about leaving
and um
yeah it's it's west virginia yeah great
place to be you made a good point that
it's it's fiscal that people can't
afford to spend time to go to their
their child's school my mom was involved
because she had the luxury of having a
husband that worked yeah probably the
only reason she had to work she never
would have been she couldn't she could
have done it so it's an economic thing a
lot of this is economic and you have no
obligation to stage your partisanship
publicly we have secret ballots for a
reason people that want a virtue signal
with signs in their yard you're welcome
to but no one is expected to do that
well that's why the joke in my
neighborhood is that the people who are
the ones you know flying american flags
which i do
that's our
way of saying that's our way it's it's
more subtle but i mean i don't think
it's really even that subtle i think
everyone in the neighborhood thinks that
i told seamus coughlin to put a rainbow
behind him a rainbow flag behind him on
the show and he said i think that would
send the wrong message and i said why
because the rainbow is god's covenant to
noah that he would not flood the earth
again and so i said why would you why
would you like not fly your own sign out
of fear that people would get the wrong
idea instead of just telling people what
the right idea is and standing behind
symbols that were historically used by
christians and he said okay maybe it's
like an actual rainbow and it says
something on it we made that and i was
like yes let's let's do that
so right now
you have people who are saying i will
not express my support for what i
believe in other than to subtly and
secretly do it in in a way like flying
the american flag okay well i i will say
that
for a lot of conservatives politics is
not our religion it's nowhere close to
our religion and the way the left views
politics it is their religion and so
you know i want to be judged by my
christian faith i want to be judged by
you know just not who i vote for and for
for me to
brand my home my car whatever with these
campaign signs with these campaign
stickers it's it's basically asking for
this
engagement with with somebody who
doesn't see the fight the same way i do
does that make sense totally yeah
there's more than two political parties
also people are blind some people are
blinded into the left right paradigm
well and that's and that's the other
thing too i have never like in the last
few elections there has not been a
candidate who i do fully support who i
do want to fly a flag for or hang up a
sign for because i don't i'm not wholly
behind that person um
and so i guess that's that's another
answer to your question but you know
when the left view
when the left views politics is religion
and i don't it takes away
my will to fight because it's like i'm
fighting with a crazy person who does
not have even the same value system as i
do but engaging these people is
extremely important it's beyond
a different value system i remember
watching uh something when i was a
little kid i remember what it was
but it was something about religion
maybe it was like something i watched in
school and it was a christian
who was captured in a conflict with
uh muslims like it was like a crusades
thing or something like that and they
told him to renounce his god and he said
no and they were like if you don't
renounce your god will kill you and he
said then i'll die
and then kill him and i thought that was
so dumb i'm like you're saying words
you're just saying words like you will
live if you just say oh yeah oh man oh
wow you're so right i i totally do and i
never understood
because i i think you know try and
survive
but now
seeing what's going on in this country
and in this world with the woke
psychotic you know nonsense
and watching star trek the next
generation
how many lights are there
and now i get it
you know so you see these people
it's not it's not just a difference of
values it is
you you see
you you see the color blue they see the
color green they literally do not see
the same thing as you yeah and so it
doesn't matter what you say to them
they will get violent oh they will they
will they will attack you because
they're in a cult and they're in my
wreck my jeep it matters what you say
you can you can communicate if they see
a symbol then that's going to be
challenging because like for instance
the not this nazi swastika was like
remnant of like a hindu symbol of the
wheel of life it's like a it's like a
mirror image of it so if i were to put a
mirror image of the swastika behind me
uh that's not going to put forth a good
message even though i know it's a symbol
of peace yeah it's going to piss a lot
of people off i was in austin and
there's an antique shop it's a famous
antique shop and they got swats that
goes all over the joint they're the real
ones not the nazi one they're the
inverted hindu ones
and i asked the guy about it and he said
he's like oh yeah i got out of my
keychain we've got mugs here and he's
like in the 19 early 1900s these were
all over everyone's houses they were
good luck symbols
and and then i was like you're not
worried about people seeing that and
he's like nope
and i was like oh okay like that's what
i'm saying like
i think that's that's bold
to be willing to be like i assert what
this means and you know do something
about it
i think there's a time and a place to
utilize symbology for your cause because
if the if the temperature was right
politically symbolism symbolism that i
could i would not say it's reference
sorry i had to do it i could show the
swastika reverse mirror image swastika
like i could do it if the environment
was was ready for it yeah there then
it's oh then you can have the discussion
and show the symbol and but otherwise
it's just it's it's like it's like a
spark when there's with wet wood it's
not gonna set anything it's not gonna
catalyze anything it's just gonna people
are like why are you setting that why
are you trying to so i'm gonna make the
symbol for individual liberty personal
responsibility and freedom like a puppy
or something yeah it's just gonna be
like a little dog like playing with a
toy golden retriever that's all it will
be a baby golden retriever on a flag
because you have the means to print
these beautiful images on flags these
days yeah and then people will be like
marching angry like like with this flag
with like a little golden retriever
puppy like playfully playing
well that's basically what the left does
right like they yeah they
they wrap their craziness and pretty
untouchable packages and then uh we're
all evil for going against yeah like the
cattle ninetails each lash is a
different color
beautiful yeah that's a great idea okay
before we move on i did want to say i
know it's different when you ask a mom
what she wants to do about it then when
you ask your dad what he's going to do
about it because moms take a very
different approach than dads can and
should and i also wanted to say that i
think this is a deeply cultural problem
because like ian was saying it does
require two incomes to survive like very
much where we are especially it's very
expensive to live i know the cost of
living isn't cheap both parents have to
be working to some extent and i
understand it's hard but at the same
time you could flip it on its head and
be that person who's so nice so friendly
and so involved in the community that
when they find out that you support
someone like i don't know um youngkin or
well santa's that's kind of always my
goal right you know i i always kind of
find that i i have a very very close
knit group of friends and it i do have a
lot i have a lot of friends guys
but you know those who
who i know feel differently than i do
politically i kind of wait right and
it's almost like i have this personal
moment where i come out to them and i i
get to kind of break it to them like
look i know you respect me as a person
as a mom as a friend i respect you and
it's it's sad but it feels like in this
area because everybody is so hyper
political um
you know you you have to kind of own or
earn that trust first as somebody who
leans conservative before you
break it to them
i got an idea oh boy what you do is you
hold a local community gathering
and you say it's going to be a big event
coming out party for pride or something
when people show up with my puppy dog
flag what they're gonna see is you get
you get a venue with a bunch of tvs and
on all the tvs are like you know rainbow
flags
and then once everyone's inside you say
everyone gather around for a group photo
and then you press a button all the tvs
turn to trump 2024
and then a bunch of trump flags unfurl
and you've taken pictures
and that's it and then you post them all
on facebook there you go instead of
gender montgomery county
instead of gender reveals you have
political party reveals yeah
all these people show up and they're all
standing there smiling for a photo that
says trump 2024 just like across the
walls banners and then you post it
online they're like i i swear that's not
what i was there for they're gonna be
like you're lying you're a trump
supporter
it would just cause so much discord
because the left likes eating each other
destroying themselves that it would
eviscerate
there was a guy
there was a guy who's going to all the
protests in 2020 and putting trump
stickers on the back of all their cars
didn't someone someone got attacked for
that i think yeah i think there was a
video of like a woman to throw a brick
through her window because someone put
us like a trump sticker on her car at
the protest or something like that
that's crazy that's vandalism by the way
yeah
yeah don't put stickers on people's cars
very bad not your property but in this
area you know even before january 6 the
the the 2020 election was so freaking
polarized like there's no way anybody in
my neighborhood even if they were a
trump supporter would have
admitted it in in it with with a yard
sign or something because you are asking
for a brick for your win sure you're
asking for that's why we have secret
ballots because people would get lynched
in the past for that kind of thing so
yep you're gonna know yeah but what you
do is okay it's it's so simple you are
right though i mean activism is so
important you have to make the case you
have to fight for your communities you
have to run for school board you have to
fight back right do you live in like a
residential area with like next door
neighbors are right next to you and
everything so what you got to do is you
got to buy what's called a ghillie suit
you know the ghillie suit oh my gosh for
a sniper right yeah it's like
it's like a bush cut you're like you're
like yeah that's what i thought it was i
was like saying this okay
you put the signs up in your yard and
then you get a couple of your friends
maybe your husband and his friends and
they just you know lie out and wait and
then when someone comes by with the
brick they just walk up very very
politely and just grab the brick and say
no
i could also home alone them right
what's that crazy movie he plays with
the tommy gun oh yeah
the two robbers joe pescia
daniel stern what an amazing voice over
actor love him he directed the rookie of
the year the the baseball movie with the
kid can throw the ball right here it's
the only time yeah
movie moment with brett yeah he was
he was the voice of the adult dude on
wonder years yeah right wasn't that him
yes
so we we had a security issue um i'm not
gonna say exactly where but you know
personal and i was like we had we have
gilly suits because luke
luke bought kelly's suits he looks great
and then i was like all right let's do
this
and then
the the issue stopped so it like we
never actually had a chance to get the
guys out in ghillie suits
yeah you got to do a whole show in them
like one whole show just
i do want to point out that like you
mentioned the the part about the
american flags i remember during the
election rogan o'hanley um the dc
draenor he pointed out is it weird that
lately just seeing an american flag i
automatically assume that they're
republican i said
because i i'm not a republican and i
know i have friends who are my last boss
at my last job was a you know blue dog
democrat uh believed in owning firearms
but was so anti-trump it was hard to
believe i don't think that's necessarily
true that uh somebody is just because
they support the american flag or that
that means that they're republican but i
definitely think that it does mean a lot
to say that they probably aren't far far
left because they're the ones who every
time you have to post something for
fourth of july there's that one dude who
has to come into your page and be like
why would you post that hate symbol of a
flag in your thing they're just there to
ruin everything well i think that's kind
of what the the issue is is that
everything is such a slippery slope now
into the culture wars and it's like okay
well i want to support you know black
lives matter
and then that turns into now i i can't
you know stand for the anthem and now
the flag is offensive and you have to
support infanticide and you have to
support in fantasy it's a it's a whole
package deal yeah and it's yeah it's
just everything feels like such a
freaking slippery slope now and nobody
wants to touch any issue sheamus made a
good point he said if anything the
left's proven it's not a slippery slope
at all it's a sheer cliff and it's just
straight down
do you think the average person is is
clued into abortion beyond the idea that
they just think it's uh i i hung out in
new york with a friend of mine i've
known for a really long time and he's uh
he talks politics sometimes and he said
this is crazy that they're they're going
to be banning abortion and stuff like
that he wasn't and he wasn't as ignorant
to think that the supreme court decision
did that he was talking about the states
okay and i said
yeah i was like i get it you know
because there there are certain issues
where there have to be exceptions and
stuff like that but look man what's the
alternative the democrats legalize
abortion to the point of birth and he
goes
what no and i was like that's the bill
they just tried to pass and joe
mentioned blocked and he goes no that's
that's not true you got to be wrong and
i and i said okay here read it and he
read it and he goes
what and i was like it says
post-viability abortion if the mother's
health is threatened right and he goes
yeah yeah that's like a medical issue
and i said what does post-viability mean
and he's like what is it i'm like it
means the baby can survive on its own
and he's like okay and then i'm like
here's the cdc definition of abortion it
ends the life of the baby
and then i'm like this bill legalizes
if the mother is is is in any way at
risk you can terminate the life of a
baby that can survive on its own and he
was like
i don't know this doesn't make sense
this can't be right and i'm like bro i
read this stuff all day every day i just
showed you what more do you have to say
well it's like 100 agenda setting theory
i mean this is it's totally
the mainstream media the media knows
that that is not what
people should hear to support them so
they just don't cover it and then people
don't know
let's say and that's like for me this is
one of those things where i didn't get
as much pushback on my social media of
people talking about roe v wade as much
as i thought i would but there was a
couple of people who i was actually
surprised talking about in a sense i was
going to bring up you know third tries
like northam tried to introduce this
ages ago and then you just then you get
into what you're talking about then you
have to have this long conversation with
someone like i don't have the time of
day dude i'm freaking busy during the
day i can't sit here and write and tell
somebody what post-birth abortion is
like you can't abort something that's
been finished that literally makes no
sense but then i have to explain that to
them and i don't have the time of day to
do that always a two-step process you
can't just say what your position is you
have to first explain to them why
they're completely misled and confused
and frankly it's a lot of work and it's
a really good way to lose friends and i
think that's a big part of the problem
is people just don't have the time of
day and doing that communication
digitally doesn't help because i know
you've talked about a lot you know the
concept of conversing with someone in
person is a lot different than the
concept of trying to talk to someone
online where there's no context where
there's no tone of voice yeah well no
even people you agree you you like you
generally like or get away or get along
with uh your tone of voice can't be
discerned your body language can't be
discerned and having such a a serious
discussion about a topic that important
when you've got 20 minutes free on your
lunch break isn't viable it's not a real
thing for instance me and elijah
schaefer he's like one of my best i
think it was one of my best i love the
guy but when we're in text man do we oil
and water it is not we do not have the
same style and i'm like i'm just not
gonna like because i know he's joking
but it doesn't seem like that in text so
i don't i'm just not messing with that
crap
he's like hey you smelly hippie yes
you know in real life
no but that feeling is the worst when
you when you get a text and and
and you know you can feel like the hair
stand up on the back of your neck you
know
it's just ugly territory that it's going
and yeah i mean but but who who has the
time to meet with these people and have
like let's let's go out to coffee and
talk politics like that sounds like
something my dad wants to do that i
don't want to do i think if within
within a week of your life you're able
to help one person open up their mind
that's enough if everyone can do that
that's enough
well and that's the that's why it's
local elections and school board
elections and stuff are so important and
you know it's so important to make time
and get involved and everything but you
know with with republicans turning into
morphing into the ones who are the
working party
they just don't have time
and and it's it's it's hard to it's hard
to represent your politics when you are
working your butt off and trying to
support your family yeah when the people
that you've entrusted with the power
bankrupt you or your surroundings then
and then are like sorry we're just gonna
take your kid for you and make sure that
it ha like it's we'll make sure that you
get money from us now you're on our on
our on our
dime
it's that's very dis
destructive for a government to do that
to its citizens i can't blame
particularly
the governors and the
the representatives and things like that
because a lot of its ignorance but
oh man
it's just so sad you know schools are
supposed to be for kids and now the
schools are places for
you know adults to
to live out their fantasies of what
they want people to believe and it's
just it's gotten really well these these
teachers have never grown up themselves
right
so
you see this in the weird creepy ways
that it manifests they have not matured
into adults they've not experienced
hardship they've not experienced
responsibility they want everything paid
for by the government but they don't
realize the government is composed
comprised of the people
so
when all these people are like the
government should provide services who
was it who told us that that was that
met binder i wasn't honest i think the
government should provide services to us
that's what the
goal of government is and i'm like okay
then who is doing it like like the
individual who is doing the government
and i'm like right by who in the
government and he's like what do you
mean it's like i don't think they just
don't understand and he said the
government will pay for it and i'm like
so they'll pay someone to do it yeah and
i'm like and where does that money come
from yeah
what do you mean they just print it
they just print it line that's my
favorite
labor is exchanged for labor currency is
a universal trade medium to make it
easier
the the resources and energy have to
come from somewhere we do not live in a
world of magic infinity that you can
just replicate food hey maybe one day
when we have replicators
maybe we'll get past a lot of these
problems how about that a lot of this
just come from taking civics out of
class in like junior high in high school
the fact that they just don't have it
anymore yeah they don't have it
they're not even offering it that they
want the kids to be as as uninformed
about the governmental process as
possible bring back home act yeah shop
yeah home equipment was good when i
realized i could cook in sixth grade
that was such a morale booth right yeah
it actually tasted good it was like it
was like a oatmeal or something
that's great yeah the concept of shop is
kind of crazy to me it's like all right
kids here's a table saw
get going well it's crazy because we did
it and we had shooting club in schools
that's fine now it's like your scissors
have to be made of plastic and you still
can't run with them ugh
you know that's what school is it's too
much safety culture everybody wear your
bubble wrap and surround yourself by
plastic cubicles so you don't cough on
each other yeah this is a result of
treating school like as if it's only for
girls you need it to be for boys as well
you need to teach boys to make stuff and
mess stuff up and fight constructively
with each other like you're fencing
there would be a lot less adderall
prescribed too if they made it
more efficiently for boys well look man
if you're a company that produces some
kind of drug for kids you're going to be
marketing as much as possible that kids
need drugs right i wonder i was just
saying about five years make money man
like how much money pfizer made off of
the pandemic so this is my critique of
capitalism that pharmaceutical companies
do good things they do they they they
create drugs and treatments that do well
yeah and then you actually have there's
a story that um so i can't remember what
it was like a pharmaceutical exec who
argued or i think it was a bank they
argued um perhaps curing things is not a
viable uh option for our long-term
revenue goals yeah because then people
don't buy your product anymore so you
need people to stay out and stay on the
drug to keep giving you money you end up
with commercials i love these
commercials where it's like is
floorbonna right for you ask your doctor
and i'm like i don't even know what the
drug does they never tell you show me a
drug i better call them and ask them
maybe i need drugs side effects are
vomiting yeah
running through like trees and
wilderness and it's like what does that
have to do with the drugs this is this
is free market suicide when big
companies
that makes a pharmaceutical like
adderall or something that affect say we
need to sell more of it how do we do it
let's lobby for a change in the
diagnostic criteria for what children
are experiences to get more kids on our
product and then get more prescriptions
and more insurance companies to pay for
it now i got a whole bunch of kids on a
whole bunch of crazy cocktails of ssris
and
and
uppers and downers and lefters and
writers and whatever else
especially after all the
school closures and the mass mandates
and all the kids missing out on major
life events it's just heartbreaking it's
like i'm looking at a puzzle that's
missing like seven it's got like a
thousand pieces and there's like 17 of
them are missing i can see it but i
don't know exactly what it is i know
that the federal reserve is in cahoots
with the pharmaceutical industry somehow
that their the government feels beholden
to the pharmaceutical industry for for
money
but that money is federal reserve money
so why doesn't the government just say
we're taking control of the finances
we're still going to print our own we're
cutting you out we don't want sick
people
you don't you don't profit off of more
sick people we don't want more sick
people you profit when there's less sick
people and the profit is a healthy
society it's not of the money you don't
need pieces of cotton in your pocket to
be healthy
you need food we need to be able to
transport the food you would have to
assume that your government would want
what is best for you and i do not at
this point
in any way
yeah it's too massive they want the
individuals in government what's best
for themselves the real question is do
you want what's best for you and i asked
that everybody that's why i stopped
eating sugar that's a good point if you
really want it you'll do it and that's
the first step because the government is
us yeah they they ask you that when
you're diagnosed with ms they're like
who is responsible for making this
better for you is it your you know your
family members whatever and i was like
it's obviously me but thanks for asking
they're like good you're going to do
great you're not going to be successful
you know what i had for dinner i had
tuna salad
it was jarred tuna oh my yeah not canned
oh no glass jars i don't think that
metal in my tuna
it was tuna salad on a bed of spinach
with cherry tomatoes and avocado
because i am eating healthy man that
sounds cause i want what's best for me
any additives every salt or anything i
think there was salt in it alison made
it i think um every time i see ian
cooking it's lentils
dude they're so good red lentils too red
lentils will splooge into a goo
thank you for that you mix it with
tomatoes sweet potatoes and carrot
boiled sweet potatoes and carrots with
boiled you boil lentils slowly over like
20 minutes you get a sauce out of it
basically confirming what i said protein
sauce
will walk in the kitchen and have stuff
like oh you're making today lentils
lentils yeah yeah a stew it's a steel
like toasted blender toast them in oil
before you put the water in and start to
boil and it breaks open pores and the
lentils so it's more uh
subservient to the to the infusion
shell yeah it works i know right
we actually have a really good idea for
a set already for the cooking show
awesome yeah i was a huge fan of gordon
ramsay's uh kitchen nightmares did you
guys ever watch idiot cause it's like
you can't smell the food you can't taste
the food but watching it is still
awesome yeah i always loved it when
gordon ramsay would like find some awful
restaurant but they had really good food
and he like it was always awesome to see
him be excited for the food being good
and then lament the bad management
it's like he's a chef who's coming in to
make your food better but he's like why
are you taking orders this way how come
no one's answering the phone and i'm
like
thank you business manager but i mean he
runs successful restaurants too it was
it was always great too when like you'd
find a small hole in the wall that was
perfect in every way and he'd be like
wow i wish people more people knew about
this place it's amazing one in louisiana
it was like that little old lady yeah
yeah that was a good episode diner's
driving he was like the best i've ever
have him remember i love guys
so much which one diners drive-ins
that was gross
i know and and like after he would eat
all that crazy food he would run on a
treadmill oh gosh i mean he had two yes
but you know he probably didn't eat as
much as people would assume he would be
eating like you think he's eating that
way every day yeah i i think the the
craziest one was when he tried eating
those ghost pepper wings and it was like
not a lot of food but it's just ghost
peppers
it's not even food why would you eat it
uh i so i don't know what that is what
is ghost pepper yeah it used to be the
hottest pepper not what calorie carolina
reaper is yeah i think so it might be
the hottest pepper on earth they
probably have hybridized something you
probably actually lost weight off of
those though oh
your face swells up he's tearing you get
sick
scorpion i think is what it's called
scorpion
so i went why would anybody eat them let
me get that name why would you eat that
i worked at a buffalo wild wings when i
was in college
and the frat guys that would come in and
order those blazing wings
that is they're they're not there to eat
that's a that's like a gross mission
they're there to show you that yeah
no yes yes nobody can nobody eats that
hot stuff to
enjoy i think they do but i don't know
how sick a weird young adult male rate
of passage yes
a bunch of different
uh spicy peppers i'm not sure the
company that you had ordered them from
oh yeah they're amazing so i decided i'm
gonna try them all and it was like
hotter hotter hotter and you see like
what is it the
icu's or whatever the temperature scale
goes up off the chart and i'm like just
put a little my palm and lick it and i'm
like sitting there breathing for five
minutes but it's real
i went to a hot sauce store there's one
at the grove in los angeles it's amazing
and i'm like what's your hottest hot
sauce and they show me this crazy stuff
and i look at it they add capsaicin to
it i'm like no no no no i want like a
real hot sauce that's naturally spicy
and then it's like carolina reaper stuff
but you can actually buy
artificially enhanced hot sauce and so i
bought a vial of it
and then it's scoville rating i think
it's called yes yeah and i brought it to
my friend's house and it was this little
vial yeah and he was like i'll try it
but before i do he dabbed it on his skin
and he's like let's just see what
happens his skin blistered
and then he was like okay i'm not eating
that isn't capsaicin the stuff they put
in pepper spray yeah yeah yeah oatmeal
resin capsaicin
you only get one tom yeah don't ruin it
no you can buy pure capsaicin too it
helps with pain oh really yeah very
interesting because it like nukes your
nerves i don't know why it works but
it's fascinating that it does it melts
your nerves off so you can't feel it i
can't feel anything anymore
i just i feel like i just ate something
spicy having this conversation i'm like
i want to eat something spicy now
yeah when you can get your body to a
point where like it's not spicy anymore
i think you can build out of it i don't
know if it's like if it's sugar or
something that makes it more spicy makes
it like almost incomprehensible yeah
shus scoville heat units
i don't know how we got to hot sauce
videos
all right everybody if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and
share the show anywhere you can take the
url posted all around and head over to
timcast.com to become a member really
got to check out our monday members only
show the after-hours show with dave
landau because we're just laughing
ridiculously it was very very funny
dave's brilliant we had dave and jamie
kilson they're both so funny it was just
hilariously hilarious and uh we're gonna
have a members only after hours show
coming up tonight 11 p.m you'll see it
on the front page it appears right there
on the front page in the top left but uh
for now we will read your super chats
nick koenig says rest in peace for their
mother
i know how bad it is to to lose a parent
my father died right before covet and i
feel for them nothing but love for them
right now man
gadsden says tim this is killing me have
you unpaused your fan mail yet i need to
send you my national divorce book also
the book is on amazon and audible now
too just look up national divorce it's
the only book on the subject
for security reasons we have to rethink
how we do mail and until then i don't
know
so i'm sorry you know we don't have it
ivan ooze says please have alex stein
come on the show tucker carlson is his
biological dad interesting request stay
tuned tomorrow
it's gonna be funny when he cancels on
us now right
waffle sensei says if everyone accepted
the risk of standing up and speaking out
then there would be no risk for standing
up and speaking out and then three
gorilla emojis yeah i think so thank you
awful sensei he's often on pop culture
crisis uh interacting with us right on
making money fly up in the air that's
right yes she does he's great
all right
let's see what we get here not that guy
says woke is destroying our culture
wizards is leading the way it is the
dragon's horde trading company does not
uh does not bow to sjw pressure luxury
gaming accessories handmade by straight
white disabled male veteran on the farm
ah
i know wizards are the dragons hoard
trading company looking it up i know
wizards of the coast and a lot of like
the magic world is gone like tabletop
gaming is like you think everything else
is woke there's nothing woker than
tabletop gaming and this is the the
problem is
it's woke capitalism yep so here's what
happens somebody makes a game where it's
you know wizards fighting each other
it's a strategy game and it's like i'm a
wizard and you're a wizard and i'm going
to cast lightning bolt it's like oh i
counter spell and uh people have fun
doing it and then
the company gets investors big gaming
companies come in and say we want to buy
this is brilliant one day they're
looking at their numbers and they're
like the q3 numbers are in
we have a tremendous amount of sales
among men 18 to 34
but how do we get women they're always
looking for the phantom demographic that
doesn't care about their game exactly
it's always about the damn thing
how can we change the game to attract
more females have you considered making
the characters frumpy and ugly
that's a good idea give them dad bods
this is what they did no they the dads
all stay good looking the women become
they they make women frumpy but it's
what i don't know what's what i don't
understand right when you have like a
magic the gathering card and there's
like a guy a character it's like he's
all ripped gideon or whatever he's like
he's like ripped and then you look at
the women and the women are like
beautiful and then and then wizards like
this is not representative of people so
we're gonna make the win all frumpy now
and i'm like okay listen hold on men are
attracted to beautiful women
women are attracted to beautiful men and
women who like women also like beautiful
women and men who like men also like
beautiful men therefore just make
beautiful people on your cards why
wouldn't you do that it's it's like
imagine
if people are attracted to people who
are attractive why try to sell them
something that's not attractive
so it makes no sense you you just kind
of
you know
this sounds really mean but i think this
this
the same logic really applies to
kind of plus size models being
integrated in all of the you know online
stores and stuff now well that's that i
get
because women are getting fatter and
fatter and so
they're trying to say like hey look at
this lady wearing clothes that you could
fit in yes but i think the issue with
that is
a woman doesn't want to see an outfit on
her
they they want to see it on a pretty
person so they can imagine that it looks
like that on them
what's that fat chick store morbid oh my
god
we were talking about the victoria's
secret documentary that's coming that
came up and there's sales tanks we
talked about this
the whole thing today because it's like
the idea is that like men uh like
superhero men right superman it's got a
12-pack not even a six-pack and the idea
is that men find that aspirational like
i'm never going to look like that but by
god if i'm not going to go to the gym
and try um and that women but then when
they would do that to the female
characters then it's unrealistic beauty
standard just like it's literally a
superhero it's not supposed to be
realistic but the idea is then they've
put that into the fashion world uh you
know what i'm saying like and then no i
i wrote an article about this for the
federalist a few years ago and
you know it was it's funny i actually
talked about my first experience going
into victoria's secret when i was like
you know 16 or whatever with my
girlfriends from high school and um it
felt like going to like the cool girls
like closet it's like a club it was it
was like it was like oh my gosh this is
so cool this is so sexy this is so
sophisticated um you know it just it
felt like i was entering a new just
place i've never been and
and
you know
the thing about
those victoria's secret angels which got
cancelled because they made people feel
bad for being so gorgeous andrea de lima
um
you know when when you wear victoria's
secret clothes you you want to put it on
you you want to imagine yourself as an
angel yeah you you don't wanna
i just feel like they really screwed up
by i'm sure i call it morbid from now on
i like that it's funny now you get to
look like megan rapina that's what i'm
saying and i'm sorry but not even a
woman who's trying to be
who knows maybe she's not adriana lima
wants to put on lingerie and look like
megan rapino like it's just it's it's
just a bad equal pay i'm gonna have
marketing i'm gonna open a big and tall
shop called morbid yeah for men i love
it so much so we we have an idea for a
show we've talked about it before right
the mall store show no
we have i think so anyway on or off i'm
not sure on or off air but we have to
we've talked about it off here on air i
think we didn't mention it mall store so
it's a show that we're putting together
where we just we get a store and then we
have we just change what the store is as
gag stores all the time just to like to
see the reactions of people who are
coming in like confused that's really
funny so we'll do morbid yeah it'll be
called morbid we'll stylize it and we'll
put like big fat mannequins
morbid yeah i i went and then what we'll
do is we'll have the uh we'll have a big
and tall section the more bed section
and the moribund section beautiful i i
feel like you can't really satirize
reality because i went to the perfume
store the other day and i saw this huge
fat model and this bright sunny looking
perfume and i was like i don't want to
smell like that model smells that's what
i'm saying i really don't think that
sounds so mean because i understand that
we are
you know
supposed to be body positive but there's
just a fine line between being body
positive and then like having lizzo on
this on the cover of like what was it
shape
or something i was uh i called someone
more abundantly obese
and then someone tried correcting me
they're like oh you mean morbidly obese
i was like no
bundle
when you're that large like your risk of
heart disease is much higher than other
people's and it's just a health fact and
we should stop pretending hey look i
lost 30 pounds i was a big boy and it
was funny because somebody somebody was
like tim we know you were fat because
after you watch your clips we have an
after another record a new ending
promoting the show and it's like from a
few months ago so i'm like bigger so my
thing is like you can you can cut up the
sugar you can get better you can be
healthy you can go for a walk let's read
some more super chats
um all right well how do you uh a
athanasios
a thonasin says love you guys need help
10 year police officer killed by drunk
driver while volunteering for fellow
officer leaving behind a loving wife and
five kids
firefighter brother had to watch him die
give send a go supporting the richardson
family
also possible to buy sneck board
not yet but soon soon soon yeah we're
actually looking at a venue
we're looking to purchase a building
which will function as a game shop skate
shop and venue for events
and that will be out in the
in eastern west virginia
what's the name of that that uh gofundme
again richardson family for it was give
send go give send go i do think
crowdfunding may be the future of a way
we get out of this uh this mess
yeah they can shut you down on
crowdfunding though if the platform
doesn't work yeah we need a
decentralized um untrackable
crowdfunding mechanism that's great oh
good i'll read more uh nathan
trimmington says tim when is the rap
song dropping
at some point i suppose raymond magaji
says dude tim how long did that take to
ace that i
so people need to understand i talk
faster than i actually talk and i have
to try to talk slower hmm all right
bench bureau so i want to hear it on
point five speed and see if it sounds
like you but warped it's going to be so
i
when i record my segments
sometimes there will be like some
important thing i have to do and i'm
like i got to get this done quick
but i don't realize that a segment is 30
minutes long regardless of how fast i'm
talking so i'll end up cramming in like
an hour's worth of content because i'll
just be like reading the news and just
going really fast and then i look at the
timer and i'm like uh talking fast isn't
making this any different i should i
could chill out just slow it down make
this listenable that's been a very big
part like for me is trying to learn how
to slow down because i'm a naturally
fast talker as well like when we're
doing the segments and i'm moving the
conversation along i get that natural
urge to kind of pick up and move along
because i don't like the idea of dead
air
so i have to slow it down
forlorn vox says lmao at tim speaking at
10 times playback speed you read that
article like it was a side effects to it
it was side effects to a shady big form
of prescription medication there you go
stunning it was like the micro machines
guy do you guys remember those
commercials micro machines faster than
the real thing
remember that guy the famous guy who
could talk super fast that was the guy
yeah that's how i was saying yeah he did
the micro machines commercials yeah i
could talk about inspiration but there
was a camera twist
and buster yeah and there was and
there's a really funny thing it says uh
buster rhymes is the fastest rapper in
the world and it cuts and says the guy
from the pharmaceutical commercials yeah
has entered the chat the law disclaimer
guy for reference it was john mashida jr
is the guy with the motor mouth john the
guy fast talking anwar abu baker says
please look into ab5 bill in california
there will be a huge disruption in the
supply chain this week possibly they are
trying to turn independent contractors
into employees to extract tax dollars
from truck drivers god bless your work
tim didn't that already pass a long time
ago i don't know
one of the videos that that you did
early on that
i when i realized how much my friends
hated uh
politics that weren't their own was
pointing that out to somebody and i got
gaslit super hard and like i pointed out
that bill and he goes well i don't doubt
that you read something like that i'm
like oh come on dude and then and then
vox fired like all of their california
all of them were axed right and they're
like we can't hire you yeah we don't do
business in california either yeah not
just for that reason for a variety of
reasons do not do business in california
if you i
the daily wire used to be in california
they move they're in nashville now sure
enough let me just say do not do
business in california if you live there
i guess
but if you are if you're any kind of
company that in any way has to do
anything in in other states so because
we're digital media we can take we can
take articles and contract people who
might be in california we won't do it
california is does not exist as far as
our company is concerned do not do
business there you'll regret it yeah you
will absolutely regret it an employee
can walk into your office take a dump on
your desk pick it up and throw it at
someone and you will get sued for it
it's insane obviously i'm exaggerating
but it's almost that bad maybe it
actually is i don't know it's just it's
brutal
you can you can have a talk with like
the labor board and i've worked in
california and i've i've been on the
other other side of that they'll they'll
tell you whatever you like if you're the
employee and you're like i have a
problem we'll go we don't care we're
going to give you whatever you want and
we're going to strip it from the
business
it's crazy wow
all right brett willett says may god
bless you ian we pray for you always may
your heart and eyes be opened to the
gospel of jesus christ dude last night
brett i was thinking i was like laying
in bed till like five in the morning
thinking about god i'm like okay this is
real cause a lot of times i feel despair
but last night i was thinking maybe the
solution is to this is bringing
people together with god
and it feels real um it's like uh
like it's uh i think it's real like it's
you you study nasim harriman's short
style proton and like
you've got these black holes in you like
the protons
really i
it's scientific it really seems like
there's something going on man
i think god is real yeah
all right
the backlash says ronald reagan gave
fireside chats from the white house
trump doing that would be phenomenal
it would be the funniest most fun thing
ever
ladies and gentlemen this is former
president donald trump from mar-a-lago
the winter white house if you did like
meme report from the white house
trump does meme review yeah new review
from the white house
that would be the coolest
so we gotta we have to we have to get
trump for the show somehow we we've
talked with a bunch of people in the
circles and like
maybe we'll go to new jersey but if we
do i will ask trump to review like three
memes
and it'll be a short thing probably like
five ten minutes but that would be the
coolest thing ever it would be so funny
for the kids we need you to review these
memes yeah gotta get that demographic
trump
and it would be funny like a political
meme just you know funny stuff yeah
watching him the npc one he'll be like
what's an npc i don't get it
that'd be great
uh dalamar says trump has a channel 2.6
million subs been there for years
streams the rallies oh okay okay yeah
but we need like
trump to be sitting watching tv and then
we get to watch his reaction to fox news
think about how amazing that show would
be if he held like watch parties on
amazon prime where he just watches like
the west wing
like no no like him watching tucker
carlson and tucker says something and
then he starts commenting on it and just
going off would be the coolest thing
ever
if trump did what i did like grab news
articles and then turn the camera start
talking about it he'd have 50 million
viewers in a week
he would be getting 5 10 million views
per clip
it would be it would be just amazing
all right the pyromaniac says trump and
desantis need to team up have trump
charge in like a bull like in 2016 let
desantis wrangle with congress and train
him upon the appropriate foreign policy
decisions and prime him for a run in
2028 with a trump endorsement
i mean i'm down you know i think
desantis is good for a lot of reasons
i think there's reasons to think trump
would be good it's tough we got to see
this primary we'll see what they say i
don't know i think that
you know if if republicans really want
to win i think that they kind of got to
ditch the trump stop i think they need
to embrace a new face i think desantis
is tough on the on stuff like trump is
and and that's why trump was so
attractive it's very similar issues but
you know why do trumpers want
why do why would republicans want
another
news cycle of just
media versus trump and trumpism and
trump like it's i just feel like it's
time to move on come on yeah you got to
define what it means to win because you
get trump into office and it definitely
not be a win for anybody well it it
won't be a win for anybody and it's just
going to be more of the same thing and
it's just time for progress
i think i don't want trump back in
office and then he makes the tweet about
elon musk or the the post about you know
musk and i want him back i'm sorry well
that's i think that if he does his own
show like what tim was suggesting that
we all win just make his own like fake
presidency give him the oval office yes
it'd be amazing to tape a show when
sometimes yes jedi mind trick 75 says
i'm always the i like ian butt guy in
the comment section but ian is steady
rolling 20s tonight he is killing my
gimmick nothing but love ian enjoying
pop culture crisis too brett thank you
love you homie who was that jedi mind
trick my mind trick i feel you
bub savvy says hey tim you should have
sam hide on before his hassan [ __ ]
fight next year
next year when's their fight oh that's
awesome interesting yeah sam hyde's a
boxing coach did you see he's gonna
fight hassan
oh i wouldn't doubt it i haven't heard
this is the first i've heard of it
though i have no idea yeah we should
have sam hyde on
yeah i like sam a lot i know him maybe
balls in there that will happen
all right
joe miles says the millennials working
in the white house think they are living
in the tv show west wing kamala's speech
writers are probably failed script
writers trying to create a quotable
one-liner i i don't think so she'd be
saying like bigger words you know yes no
i actually that was the first thing i
thought it was that it sounds like
they're trying to write an endearing
speech that's really easy to digest and
they're just bad at it but it's her
delivery is too off to actually buy that
no i think word salads i think what
they're doing is camel is like i need a
speech for tonight and they she texts
them like i need a speech and they go
okay and they keep hitting the middle
button of the predictive test
and they just let it go and they're like
that's good send and then she goes oh
copy and paste that sentence
let an ai write her speeches that's what
they're doing
i honestly think nobody's writing
anything she's just sitting there and
she has nothing to say and she's like
well they're like what do you think we
should do about the border well
the border
is an issue
that a lot of people have thought about
when it comes to the issues
okay countries have borders we are a
country
that borders another country
which means a border yeah and there are
people she's got a group like she's got
like a writing team sitting on a table
doing this they're all throwing ideas in
yeah border say that again again
michael schwabel how many people right
now know their neighbors most have
already been split from them through the
way of
our way through the way out culture
functions do you know your neighbors i
do
neighbors my neighbors say howdy
neighbor
i wave to them when i take my kid to
daycare
when i come home
sometimes
we waved each other over the fences but
you know i just moved to my my
neighborhood kind of recently and covet
has made it hard to connect with people
do you think you'll have to fight them
i you know what
malcolm ned said we got to go
outside they would lose
i
yeah that's right
all right
patrick reichert says total non-sequitur
but ian curious when you saw foo
fighters i have seen them 10 times and
they're my favorite band taylor hawkins
loss has really affected me yeah that
was brutal uh i think it was 2003
about it was an incredible show too that
was the closest i ever got to really
like just screaming and throwing my arms
in the air that's crazy they were they
were getting ready for like a tour or
something right they were on tour they
were
how did he die was like cardiac arrest
or something i don't know uh
i don't remember if there anything came
out about that i know that he had there
was like a bunch of drugs in the hotel
room but they said that he never used
before shows so it didn't it didn't fall
in line that's the problem with heroin
use a lot of in hard really heavy drugs
is if someone does it in the same
environment over and over their body
when you walk into that room the body
gets ready for it it puts the things
ready to counter the heroin so then when
you go to a new environment you use that
same amount you're there's no your
body's not ready for it and it can shock
the system yeah i mean beyond the fact
that it could just have been tainted or
there could be any number of things that
is wrong with it that cause those
problems one of the best i actually have
a like a light-hearted story about foo
fighters so dave grohl i think is from
maryland right he's
right okay so so they were
i was with my husband when we were still
dating a few years ago we were on youth
street we're walking around and there
was a part of youth street that was you
know under construction so it was like
one of those times what are they called
scaffolding yeah and
it's just us
walking one way and then a group of men
in black and stuff are coming at us and
i kind of look at them but i'm trying
not to be a weird stare
and i realize oh my god that's the
freaking foo fighters and i say oh my
god that was the foo fighters and dave
croll because at this point we had past
each other mocks me he goes let me get
at the bib
and i was like david just mocked me we
got to the bar where we were headed i
was like you guys dave girl just mocked
everyone's like you're lying we looked
it up sure enough they're on tour and it
was them and yeah i have been an even
bigger fan of them since because that
was so funny
yeah i was mocked by the rules
i used to live near the metro in chicago
yeah are you familiar with the venue at
all anybody no
so it's like a thousand seater and uh
it's like a really popular spot so i'm
it's right next to wrigley field as well
so i'm a few blocks down i can't
remember the name of the street he's off
clark and me and my friend were busking
playing music on the street when
everyone's out at the bar is getting
ready for the show
and uh i'm a big fan or i i used to be a
really big fan of death cab for cutie i
don't really touch a lot of their stuff
these days but uh so i knew all their
songs and so i'm playing a ton of their
songs and then i looked at my friend and
i'm like let's just play an original
that i wrote we start playing and then
as i'm playing ben gibbard the lead
singer and a couple other guys walk past
and they look and they're like you know
like nod and keep walking and then i'm
like sitting there i'm like i look like
ben gibbon and then i was my friend
she's like yeah aren't they playing at
the metro tonight which is like two
blocks away and i was like no way i
thought it was funny if the one time i
stopped playing covers of his band was
when he actually walked past me and then
i was just like wow that was crazy
i actually got to meet them once it was
really cool i got to meet chris wallace
was a really cool dude
talk to him about music cool guys really
that's awesome love their music
all right what do we got more what more
do we got
what do we got more waffle sensei says
if you are not fighting for hearts and
minds and souls and you're only fighting
to win then all you want is power and
you deserve none of it
yeah the betterment of your enemies
i guess the idea is to make everything
better a rising tide lifts all ships
correct all right
cj mclean says i usually listen to the
show the day after and download it to my
phone with youtube premium for some
reason i can't download the episode from
712 this isn't the first time this has
happened not sure if you guys or youtube
is censoring
what was on the 12th adrian and libby
really yeah sometimes things just happen
and it's not necessarily something yeah
that level there's a thing about that
with youtube so we can always download
our own episodes after we stream but
like one in ten or like one in 20 yeah i
can't yeah it's just a problem yeah and
there were issues so here's is really
funny we have at issues where like we we
we manually record the show yeah and
then afterwards we use that recording
for all the clips because the live
streamed version has artifacting or
downrez or something like that but there
have been instances where i've screwed
up or around a hard drive space where
things crashed and we should probably
check that actually and um then we're
like we'll just download it from youtube
and we can't so we have to screen
capture our own show we have to like
load it let it run for two hours and
just record so that we can make clips
again because you can't download it and
and the way live streams work these
third-party downloading things don't
work either they may have fixed it maybe
it's changed but we've had those it is
brutal that's frustrating
yeah
all right let's see what we got in the
old super chat lineup
james riley says politics is not a
litmus test for good and evil we should
be free to disagree with that reprisal
otherwise the fringes on both sides win
yes but the fringes on the right will
actually talk to you they'll they'll
they demand to be debated
and then you and then but i mean like
conservatives um you know want to have
the conversation even far right as
extreme as they get want to have the
conversation and prove to you why
they've come to their conclusions the
left is a cult and they're like nope
don't want to hear it get out don't care
the epitome of cancel culture
silence where it comes from
all right let's grab some more super
chits
deadeye says tim and gang look into
super tasters and non-tasters when it
comes to eating spicy foods
uh
someone told me that i was a super
taster and i don't know if that's true
but i said i didn't like cilantro and
they said does it taste like soap and i
said no and they said then why don't you
like it i said it overpowers everything
and they're like oh so you probably
don't like alcohol either and i was like
right and they're like okay you're
probably a super taster oh that's
interesting and i was like uh
i guess i could never understand how
people sip
whiskey no because me neither yeah
that's it i'm like i don't know if that
makes you a super taster because you
don't like to drink that stuff that's
crazy because ever since i had covet i
can taste alcohol really strongly wow
and cilantro kind of similarly so i
wonder if it's kind of changed my taste
buds like that weird the real question
is why do people know what soap tastes
like yeah that's a great question
because they swore as a kid that's right
they got their house washed out
yeah
and then my mom cried she felt so bad
i was like just being a 13 year old
[ __ ]
and i was dropping off bombs and she was
not having it and i sat on the toilet
like that scene in a christmas what's
called a christmas journal yes and it
was disgusting and horrible and i know
exactly what soap tastes like it's like
they say cilantro tastes the way so uh
soap smells you know
okay like you'll smell something and
then taste and go oh the funny thing is
you have the worst thing you ever go to
a mall and they have auntie anne's and
it's the best smell in the world so you
buy one and you're like it's not that
good yes it's like i am very
disappointed in how this tastes versus
how it smells smells better than what's
up with that i don't know
i mean to be fair i've got like candles
that are like strawberry cheesecake that
smells so good
[Laughter]
it would not taste good
it's a bummer though
all right
sign of luck says what are your thoughts
about a populist purple desantis or
trump tulsi gabbard ticket i'm down for
it
like i really don't see a trump gabbard
thing happening what about descent to
scabbard that would be um
i'm sold
right away
left would have to run newsom though for
that to be as maximum
entertaining as possible desantis
gabbard ticket tulsi solves the foreign
policy questions
when it comes to desantis and i'm just
like
count me in i think you know i met tulsi
recently when we were in new york it was
great i'm a big fan she's shown herself
to be one of the few principled
politicians i've ever seen there's a
handful of republicans we've had in the
show that i think are cool but uh that
would be awesome and i think it would be
unifying too it would it would shut down
the left people on the right would be
like we get it the left would be
screaming and pounding their feet
amazing all right my friends if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show if you really do
like it and head over to timcast.com to
become a member we're gonna have an
after hours uncensored show for all of
you we're gonna be doing a lot a lot to
reform the website and structure things
so i think we're gonna be calling like
the after show the after hours
uncensored or something like that
separating so it's easier to find
launching other shows with your support
we will do much much more so we really
do appreciate it
uh so you can smash the like button like
i said you can follow me at tim cast and
follow the show at tim cast irl vanessa
do you want to shout anything out um
yeah my company is uh
red renegade public relations red
renegade pr and you can follow me on
twitter i'm vanessa santos xo
right on
uh guys if you want to follow me on
instagram it's at brett dasvik but more
importantly youtube.com pop culture
crisis 3 p.m eastern standard time
monday through friday me and mary have a
lot of fun with various members of the
of the crew here talking about uh movies
television pop culture everything like
that it's it's a great time and the
show's been growing steadily we're
really doing it and if you super chat
you can fire money at them it's true
while they're talking it mainly goes
with the guests but it goes yeah it's so
great it goes right by me and mary's
face every time and it's it's a lot of
fun ian's gonna be on tomorrow that
guest will be me yes so fire your super
chats into my coffee and into my face
it's gonna be fun that actually happened
to hannah claire yeah the other day yeah
yes right in the ring not a joke it is
it is quite real um great to meet you
vanessa it was great to meet you thank
you so much you guys follow me through
social media ian crossland.net you can
find all my portals there and i'm all
over the place so hit me up anywhere you
want to and if you haven't clicked the
bell button yet in addition to clicking
like and subscribing to the channel hit
the bell button so you get notifications
when we go live when videos go up see
you later correct and you guys make sure
that you're tuning in to pop culture
crisis at 3 p.m eastern standard time
and as you know politics is downstream
of culture so then you can tune in to
irl at 8 pm eastern standard time you
guys can follow me on twitterminds.com
at sourpatchlist as well as patchlist.me
we will see all of you at timcast.com
for the uncensored after show thanks for
hanging out
you